welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of hawkeye
episode five ronin which confirms
kingpin as the mcu's mr grinch whose
heart only grows three sizes when he
needs a rush of blood too
throw a trust a bro truck at you
there are so many great details hidden
throughout this episode with yelena
belova's fascinating backstory so let us
break it all down scene by scene for
everything that you might have missed
and our friends at short fox start
giving away the first comic solo series
to feature kate bishop stick around to
the end of this video to learn how to
enter to win the episode opens with some
familiar audio all moments from the
black widow film the opening sound
effect was the same sound of the moment
the antidote spray hit yelena and woke
her up from her programming
then yelena explaining what that
antidote is to natasha it's a synthetic
gas it's a synthetic gas the
counteragent to chemical subjugation
antidote control
then attached at the end of the movie
handing the elena that list of widows
and the antidote he had widows that
planted all over the world
you should be the one to tell them it's
over we had widows that planted all over
the world
molina will need to copy the formula but
you should be the one to tell them it's
over and then this whistle
this was how the sisters signal each
other throughout the movie
[Music]
but this precise whistle audio was
actually elena at natasha's grave in the
post-credits scene
[Music]
now this opening scene of pocket episode
5 is set in 2018 so that makes the
elena's final whistle here come in from
a future moment after natasha's death so
all of this is echoing through time as
kang explained time is happening all at
once flat circle yada yada now the
mountain landscape is so frozen over
that the opening shot almost looks
monochromatic like a black and white
throwback to an older era but also a
hint to the monochromatic dust that
yelena will soon transform in and out of
this mountain range also kind of looks
like sokovia age of ultron did use the
real-life aosta valley in the italian
alps their target anna could have
profited from the chaos in that region
following the avengers battle there
yelena is back in her white tactical
gear that she was wearing at the end of
black widow but she's got a new vest
since she gave her old one to natasha
she's joined by a fellow widow sonia
who's not in black widow in the music in
these opening moments and really
throughout the episode is lauren balf's
black widow score
on a flings a t-plate at yelena elena
does not even flinch as it zips past her
face and then anna throws some cgit at
sonia but the antidote is ineffective i
don't think she was brainwashed what you
thought i was some rich perverts
prisoner she's referring to drakov who
creepily programmed his widows but also
telling us that anna was totally aware
that dracoff was doing that to the other
widows of course this being 2018 should
have been a clue to you that this would
either be post snap or snap imminent
confirmed as the elena goes into the
bathroom and finds water running through
her disintegrated hands and it's such an
affecting sequence that the director's
burton birdie unfold in 60 seconds of
unbroken camera movement recalling the
similar chaos of monica rambo's blip
return in wandavision but they're super
clever with the blocking if you look
closely elena shuts the door on her way
in but somehow the camera glides in with
her without getting bumped by the door
and then on the other side of the blip
the door is now back open as it would be
in a house five years later with no one
in there lucky for elena that was the
case but i think they actually vfx that
door and sold it being there with that
shutting door sound effect all to pull
this off as a private moment while still
allowing for more fluid camera movement
because by doing this all in one take it
plants us inside of yelena's point of
view showing us how for snap victims
this was a quick confusing transition
they didn't even blackout or faint for
them time passed instantaneously and
their worlds around them shifted and
unlike the characters we saw dust in
infinity war elena doesn't seem to feel
it happening maybe since she is always
living with a sense of unease and
physiological detachment and then even
after elena completes her own dust
transition from her perspective the
surfaces of the bathroom the color of
the walls the mirror frame the light
fixtures won't warp but on a delay it's
such an interesting way to show the
passage of time in this instant with
reality reconfiguring piecemeal also
evoking the way reality warps due to
wanda maximoff's witchcraft and venom's
transference into the mcu this all just
feels like reality stone based reality
manipulation this in the mcu is what it
looks like when characters are
transported in and out of reality i like
how anna's new daughter plays on a
little schroeder piano beside her
husband and anna says they adopted which
is a painful reminder that these widow
assassins are unable to bear children
from forced hysterectomies also maybe
this girl could have been an orphan from
parents who dusted if so that would be a
bummer custody battle i like how anna
remains all about that mercenary life
because despite all the little family
cosmetic changes she's made to the home
she still keeps up that mural that
depicts a boar hunt meaning that in her
heart she is still a hunter as the elena
still feels she must be kate bishop
returns to her childhood bedroom which i
gotta say despite being destroyed along
with the rest of that house in 2012 now
looks to be fully reassembled and left
this way for kate kate now has a hawkeye
poster on her wall and eleanor tells her
it just means that what you do might
look a little different than you dreamed
of as a child
and preferably a little less reckless
ever wanted to be reckless i just wanted
to help you i know hon
recklessness is the unfortunate side
effect just another example of how
eleanor groomed her daughter to expose
her to danger this is not a normal
mother-daughter relationship similarly
based on lies is the relationship
between qazi and maya qazi nurses her
wounds the same way eleanor did kate's
these are the scars from the elena's
widow's bites that latched onto maya's
chest last episode kazi though only
wants maya to stop pursuing the ronin to
keep his betrayal of her father a secret
meanwhile elena finds kate back at her
home
[Music]
hi
she's mac and cheese mac and cheese
being elena's dinner pick when she was a
kid and black widow i want mac and
cheese oh you want mac and cheese okay
well we have to wonder if elena ever
really intended to heat it up with all
that sriracha she might have just dumped
it all on after kate threw it at her
like some kind of hot ones alpha mind
games whatever you throw at me i drink i
drink it up elena wears a similar yellow
and black outfit that she wore in the
black widow post-credits scene and once
again she has a number of pins on her
lapel in this scene you can see a spider
maybe for her black widow history finger
guns maybe a nod to her wrist based
widow bites in a margarito glass cause
the girl drinks and she tells kate i'm
not going to hurt you
i promise
i don't have any weapons on me
okay i take that back i don't have any
weapons
currently in my hands that's a lie also
yeah elena is totally playing games from
the moment their interaction begins she
knows that rolling up her sleeves she's
gonna reveal to kate her widow's bites
and that's because this whole friendly
chat is really an interrogation in order
to threaten kate and to learn clint's
location but elena takes her time she
says come on take a fork eat
eat please my daddy says it's good for
you of course referring to the big
appetite of alexi shostakov who forced
her and natasha to dine with them in
order to make peace and then elena tells
kate well
it's my first time in new york but i do
want to see some things i want to see
the empire state building uh the new and
improved statue of liberty and
the rockefeller center the new and
improved statue of liberty of course
referring to the remodeled lady liberty
that we see in spider-man no way home
with a giant captain america shield and
her green oxidation restored to her
original copper color with the rogers
musical billboard and the no way home
promo clip marvel studios wants to make
it clear that these events are in the
same city in the same era of mcu history
she also mentions rockefeller center
reminding us that the finale episode
will take place at 30 rock the nakatomi
tower in this die hard homage then elena
gushes about christmas i love american
christmas is the tree
the presents the super powered reindeer
rudolph
he's so weird
have you ever eaten reindeer yeah again
elena is plain nice but to her remember
christmas is a dark lie as we learn in
black widow their spy family would stage
opening empty christmas presents for
fake family photos in home movies but
for young elena she bought into that lie
and it was real to her and then elena
begins to show her cards sometimes
you're funny kid bishop do you keep
saying my whole name just to point out
that you know it
yes
i know a lot about you yeah this
interrogation is so well structured it's
a lot like hans landa wearing down that
farmer and inglorious bastards the
pleasantries lead to the hunter's
reputation and then the hunter having
actually done their homework until
finally the hunter just lays it all out
are you in new york to talk to clint is
that why you're here no no no no no no
i'm here to kill him
and then elena finally arrives at the
one question she really only needs to
ask kate so
where is he
i don't know
[Music]
okay
yes after all that lecturing kate about
how we are defined by our actions not by
flashy words like hero or avenger loren
valve's black widow theme returns here
framing both of these women as soon to
be deconstructed versions of the heroes
that they once worshipped meanwhile
clint does the walk of shame that i did
after getting mephisto wrong
[Music]
grylls lets clint crash with him missy
dropped off the new outfits for you and
kate you wanna see him yeah missy is
that larper leader from past episodes it
sounds like she stitched some new
matching suits for clint and kate that
will get revealed in next week's finale
meanwhile eleanor called the cops on
jack it seems these are detectives
coddle and rivera we actually saw
detective coddle back in episode 2. he
doesn't seem to be like a fake actor
that eleanor hired this guy really seems
to be a legit cop in the comics both
these characters are lapd detectives but
as jackets cuffed he says i'm telling
you the only sloane i've ever known was
this woman i did it in palm beach and
she was an absolute nightmare yeah it's
hard to get a read on exactly what's
going on here because it does seem like
jack is putting on some kind of
performance like this is all set up so
that jack would be taken away the moment
kate walked in through the door and it
seems like it was a show to temporarily
stop kate from pursuing this
investigation in order to give eleanor
and it sounds like kingpin some time to
frame clint
ronin for killing armand at which point
they could send in some lawyers in order
to get jack out of that tax issue and
move on with business as usual of course
that plan gets ruined when kate sees a
photo of her mom with kingpin so clint
visits a battle in new york memorial
that's on the bridge that leads to grand
central in pershing square this is the
exact spot where the six of them first
teamed up in the iconic circle shot in
avengers and clint removes his hearing
aid when he talks to natasha in order to
silence the world around him which is so
sweet when you consider all the other
times that he silenced everything on
this series now we know so that he could
be alone with his thoughts about natasha
and he tells her you always had to win
didn't you
and for a stupid orange rock of course
referring to the soul stone which she
won sacrificing herself to acquire that
that left clint one second holding
natasha in his hand to the next second
holding this stupid orange rock in his
hand he also says i've replayed that a
million times in my head hoping for a
different outcome recalling how dr
strange played through over 14 million
different outcomes but only one
victorious one that still required the
sacrifice of a fellow avenger now among
kate's trophies and medals in her room
is a photo of her and her father derek
hiking reminding us that there's still a
mystery to that guy that we have yet to
know also a boomerang which might be why
she suggested boomerang arrows to clint
last week then on our bulletin board is
a magazine page of clint with the words
hero worship and then on the left a
ticket for the bishop security holiday
party december 24th 2024 again setting
the stage for the climax in the finale
then the tracksuits ivan and tomas
listen to some holiday jams
this is run dmc's christmas and hollis
it's another homage to die hard when
argyle plays it while driving mclean to
nakatomi plaza is any christmas music
this is christmas music tomas runs
through some other famous tracksuit
wearers in pop culture tommy smith was
the olympic track runner who gave the
black power salute at the 68 games he
also mentions the royal tenenbaums
referring to ben steller and his two
kids in the west anderson film and of
course tony soprano hey forget about it
and this is me totally reading into the
word play here but they debate whether
or not they themselves are royal
tenenbaums and in german tannenbaum is
christmas tree in episode three we saw a
bunch of christmas trees getting stuck
to these bozos so not intentional i i
just like seeing patterns where patterns
don't exist clint calls his wife she's
got her hands on the watch
she looked into her family glenn we've
been so careful really i mean the kids
and i are so far away if i don't end
this tonight it's just a matter of time
before the big guy gets involved jesus
are you sure yeah still no firm answers
on what exactly that avengers rolex is
all about it could be linked with nick
fury and have a scroll asset list as
i've speculated or it could be the
property of phil coulson who did wear
rolexes as we've seen in past films and
this show could confirm as him still
being alive which would officially
canonize agents of shield in the main
mcu along with these netflix marvel
characters but ultimately it does sound
like the bartons are in some kind of
government relocation program and that
laura was also part of that life of
spycraft so it is still possible that
she could be an ex-mockingbird but we'll
find out next week clint lures maya to
the fat man used car lot the same auto
shop where he killed her father and
notice how the camera focuses on that
fat man part of the sign another
reminder that the track suits probably
name this front after their boss maya
and clint fight she throws a bullet clip
at him i love that each time the sword
strikes her prosthetic leg it makes a
nice ping sound
no larper foley art is necessary clint
reveals that he was the ronin who killed
her father after he was tipped off by an
informant in their ranks that was
approved by their boss aka uncle aka
kingpin and he says that both of them
are really weapons being manipulated by
bigger power players in the shadows and
as maya leaves the neon sign shines used
as she must feel in this moment kate
calls an uber for their getaway hey are
you tabitha yes it's unrelated but
tabitha was the name of mr harrington's
wife who faked her dusting to leave him
one of my favorite random subplots in
the marvel cinematic universe so i guess
you could see this as a kind of name for
mcu women trying to flee under false
pretenses maya suspects cazzy as that
informant who tipped off the ronin and
led to william's death but she doesn't
act on it yet
maya's gonna kill kazzy
kate tells clint i spoke to her she said
she's natasha's sister
elena interesting so while natasha's
past with her spy family was a total
secret to pretty much everyone she did
tell clint about her which makes sense
considering she knew about his secret
family i just like knowing how much
these two characters knew about each
other and loved each other and then
after they get dropped off clint gives
kate an arrow remember eleanor gave kate
her first bow and now clint gives her
the arrow i think that was the one that
she used to knock the sword out of
maya's hands in order to save his life
making this a kind of token that their
mentor apprentice relationship is
restored elena tails eleanor to this
fancy building now just to be clear this
is not lot palace hotel where eleanor's
charity event was held in episode 1
which was the same location as kingpin's
presidential hotel residents in
daredevil season 3. we don't know what
this building is yet but notice that
elena looks up at the building and seems
to register something about it meaning
this might be the mcu's disk tower now
we are still waiting to see who avengers
tower was sold to tom holland signaled
that he knew who but i have not yet seen
spider-man no way home yet so i cannot
confirm anything about that but by the
time you're watching it i may actually
be in the movie theater watching it so
we'll know soon but yelena texts kate
that she knows who hired her to kill
clint and that was eleanor bishop
confirming that val must work for
eleanor and that eleanor's partner in
crime all this time has been well that's
the guy i've been worried about this
whole time
kingpin boom are you looking for fisk
yes that sure is vincent d'onofrio
wearing a white jacket and sporting a
cane the episode's credits credit
vincent onfrio who also tweeted
confirmation quoting his when i was a
boy line from the netflix daredevil
series as you suspected based on the
many clues the laugh the cufflinks uncle
is indeed kingpin wilson fisk kingpin is
of course the recurring marvel villain
to spiderman to daredevil to many new
york-based characters and really there
is no limit to what upcoming mcu titles
he could now appear in most likely echo
but perhaps also armor wars or secret
invasion i'm seeing no way home soon so
who knows maybe there too kevin feige
also confirmed charlie cox daredevil
would be joining the mcu from the
netflix side of the universe as well in
the past the netflix shows would
occasionally reference the mcu in the
battle of new york but until now the
official mcu titles never once
referenced the netflix world or
characters i'm not sure if d'onofrio
kingpin's arrival means every netflix
marvel character is automatically mcu
canon since i doubt disney plus would
want to tell all their viewers to spend
hours and hours catching up on seasons
of storylines on their rival netflix
even though you totally should because
those shows are pretty great rather we
may be looking at a kind of soft reboot
in which these versions of wilson fisk
and matt murdock are really variants in
this universe the mcu separate from the
characters we were left with at the end
of daredevil season 3 on netflix they're
still essentially the same characters
with the same relationships just with a
slightly altered history that in this
case ties kingpin to the tracksuits back
in 2007 and gives him some history with
ron and clint during the blip i go into
all this in another video you should
check it out but then the credits go
into thorough ravenscroft's classic
you're a mean one mr grinch which is
perfect for a lonely jerk who glares
down at us from his tower it's also the
kind of winky villain theme that recalls
the tone of it's been agatha all along
but it also indicates that there may yet
be a heart in there two sizes too small
buried under all that bulk a heart that
belongs to vanessa embarrassed me in
front of her
and i love this the final shot of the
credit sequence now includes the massive
silhouette of kingpin looming over clint
and kate in the city casting him as the
literal big bad that towers over the mcu
now this is the same kind of image loki
left us with with kang and that eternals
left us with with the celestials or even
just a shape in the sky always there
always watching like the watcher somehow
of all of these characters kingpin has
me the most terrified and we are
partnering with shortbox to give away a
9.8 rated copy of hawkeye number one the
first solo series featuring kate bishop
the comic is currently valued at around
250 dollars and that value will only be
going up as haley steinfeld's kate makes
her way into even more marvel properties
short boxed is the easiest and safest
way to buy and sell graded comic books
you can download short box for free at
ios and android they have an incredible
selection of graded comics they have
everything from recent favorites to the
first appearances of the x-men or
spider-man some of the most valuable
comics in the world all orders are fully
protected and insured for both buyers
and sellers thousands of the most
respected dealers and collectors in the
industry trust shortbox and use it every
day so to enter this giveaway visit
shortboxed.com new rockstars to enter
and receive a promo code for 15 off your
first short boxed order again that's
shortboxed.com
new rockstars to support our channel
check out one of our great merch options
at newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
the new rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything marble thanks for watching
always watching kingpin
[Music]
you